bonjour jean marc alors après les
masques les tests et les vaccins c'est
le projet de passeport vaccinale que la
france est en retard ou la france est en
retard alors que les entreprises le
réclame et l'europe l'annoncent pour la
mi juin si on en croit thierry breton
alors c'est moi jean marx ce passeport
vaccinale à bien écouter pour beaucoup
de chefs d'entreprise en effet ce serait
un élément important essentiels qui
permettrait de réouvrir l'activité
totalement sans beaucoup de risques
c'est très simple c'est un certificat
qui permettrait de garantir la sécurité
sanitaire en attestant qu on a été
ouvert signer ou alors qu'on est
immunisée
parce qu'on a contracté la maladie
auparavant et qu'on aurait des anticorps
mais ce document plus aussi prouver
qu'on a subi un test pcr dans les 72
dernières heures et que testés négatifs
alors ce document serait établie
évidemment par l'administration
officielle qui le préparent assez
lentement faut le dire ils pourraient
être digitalisées avec un qr code
d'ailleurs qui permettrait d'être visées
sur son smartphone par exemple il
pourrait aussi être présenté avec un
document sur papier techniquement
l'établissement du certificat ne pose
aucune difficulté aucune difficulté
technique aucune difficulté digital et
puis ils présentent évidemment beaucoup
davantage pour voyager d'abord c'est
bien ce à quoi on pense en premier c'est
ce que l'europe et s'être préparés mais
c'est aussi un document qui pourrait
permettre d'accéder je vous le disais
aux différents lieux de travail ou de
loisirs est évident que les entreprises
je répète mon intérêt et font pression
pour ce document afin de s'assurer de la
non contagion de leur personnel et puis
de leurs clients et est-ce que ça
permettrait de rouvrir les restaurants
ben écoute et ce sont les restaurants
qui sont en première ligne
alors il ya les restaurateurs qui
l'attendent les théâtres des cinémas les
musées aussi les stades de sport ça
pourrait être la seule solution à partir
du mois de mai juin pour redémarrer une
activité presque normal alors s'ils
passent pas vaccinale n'était pas prêt
pour un tas de raisons ils tout le monde
réclame au minimum des tests antigénique
sont aussi restés dans des placards des
tic
auto test qui permettrait très
facilement de s'auto tester avant de
rentrer dans un restaurant par exemple
ou ou même avant de rentrer dans une
salle de classe tenait la rentrée
scolaire ch qui va démarrer à la fin du
mois n'est pas très préparé pour ça ou
mieux des tests pcr real empêche
d'ailleurs de combiner les autotests
s'il était positif de les faire vérifier
par un test pc mais ça permettrait
évidemment d'écarter les gens qui sont
positifs la reprise de la vie économique
et sociale a besoin de tel laissez
passer et finalement alors c'est thierry
breton d'ailleurs le commissaire
européen à bruxelles qui a parlé aussi
de ce certificat sanitaire au niveau
européen qui pourrait être disponible à
la fin du mois de juin dit il afin qu'on
puisse être utilisé pendant l'été
notamment pour gérer
si vous voulez les grandes migrations
liées à auve à caen s'assurer la
mobilité de ses vacances en évitant bien
sûr d'être testé à chaque instant il
suffirait de prépa de présenter son
passeport mais alors je marquais ce
qu'il serait obligatoire en europe
alors évidemment c'est la grande
question c'est une question qui a des
effets politiques
thierry breton peut pas l'affirmer ça
mais ça dépendra finalement des
différents états membres pascal états
membres sont souvent mais en réalité si
on réfléchit bien il se posera pas ne se
posera pas parce qu'il sera forcément
obligatoire pour faire un certain nombre
d'activités pour prendre l'avion
il faut déjà apporté la preuve qu'on est
à peu près immunisés vaccinés ou ou
protéger même si on ne la surveille pas
avec toute l'attention qu'il faudrait
dans les aéroports français notamment
pour prendre l'avion pour rentrer dans
un restaurant le danemark l'islande la
suède de norvège la grèce ont déjà
quasiment rendu obligatoire pour tous
les voyageurs alors cela dit le projet
ne fait pas l'unanimité c'est vrai
d'abord parce que certains pays
utilisent des vaccins qui n'ont pas reçu
l'agrément de l'autorité de santé
européennes et là on revient sur le
débat de sa marche du spoutnik fameux le
vaccin russe qui est indiqué qu'ils
aient pu utiliser pratiquée dans
certains pays européens comme la hongrie
mais qui n'est pas reconnue dans les
autres pays il faut donc là attendre la
reconnaissance des autorités européennes
ensuite il faut reconnaître une
population
c'est un peu comme en allemagne on l'a
vu dans le dans leurs reportages
précédents ils sont pas enthousiastes à
mais peut-être parce qu'elles n'ont pas
encore été totalement vacciner dans des
proportions importantes ce qui
permettrait
garantir l'immunité collective
actuellement on doit avoir 13 millions
de primo vaccinées en france n'est pas
suffisant pour dire que finalement on
est on est protégé puis la france est
effectivement retard dans la mise en
oeuvre ce type de projet parce qu'il
existe quantité de strates
administratives de lourdeurs
bureaucratiques qui freinent qui bloque
l'idée il faut des autorisations partout
comme depuis le début de la pandémie
d'ailleurs la france risque fort de
manquer de vaccins
du coup elle se refuse à prévoir un
passeport vaccinale qui serait
obligatoire
à l'intérieur de ce pays je crois pas
qu'on puisse en parler encore très
rapidement et je crois qu'il sera ça
pense pas du tout à l'ordre du jour au
conseil de sécurité
ce matin le président d'un public reste
très très prudents là dessus nous sommes
le pays de l'égalité
c'est ça créé l'égalité or ce projet il
revient pas elle va partager les
populations vous aurez ceux qui sont
vaccinées d'un côté puis ceux qui ne le
sont pas eh bien on est très réticent
pour pratiquer ce genre de de
séparatisme si j'ose dire comme on est
très précise très réticents pour
pratiquer d'isolement on a beaucoup de
mal notamment à isoler les cas positifs
quand ils arrivent à l'aéroport on a
même beaucoup de mal à isoler les cas
positifs à l'école ni sèche ou dans les
entreprises d'autres n'hésitent on
hésite et c'est bien le drame français
alors cette situation est très ambiguë
elle va nouer ou préparer des semaines
qui vont être compliqués parce que de
deux choses l'une où on reste confinée à
la fin de l'été à la fin du printemps la
six qui sera pas accepté un par la
population parce que la situation
devient dans certains cas insupportable
ou alors on va d confiné l'ensemble de
la population sont finalement isoler les
cas positifs et dans ce cas là on prend
le risque d'une nouvelle flambée de
virus à l'automne qui sera pas mieux
acceptée merci beaucoup jean-marc
l'édito échos de jean martinez et tous
les mercredis matin donc la matinale de
rtl france à la semaine prochaine